all right it's official I told you the
beginning of the year 2018 will be and
is now becoming the year of the
boomerang and our top story tonight
after months of ringing the alarm about
the abuse of power within the FISA Court
system
well the DOJ Inspector General has
finally now announced plans to
investigate alleged foreign intelligence
surveillance abuses we've been calling
for this this of course by the DOJ in
the FBI now we have been exposing how
the unverified Clinton bought and paid
for dossier filled with Russia and
Russian government lies and propaganda
misinformation was used as evidence to
extend a FISA warrant on a trump
campaign associate Carter page we also
showed you how circular reporting from
Michael Isikoff in Yahoo News citing the
phony dossier was intentionally used by
the FBI's an attempt to straight
strengthen their finds abuse case
against Paige now we have unearthed
shocking conflicts of interest in
extreme anti-trump bias sadly at the
highest levels of the FBI in the DOJ but
we are finally one step closer to
getting to the bottom line truth and
what is the biggest abuse of power
scandal in this history of this country
and of course we deserve to know the
truth and we are revealing the real and
ever-present danger to have the powerful
tools of intelligence in the deep State
used against the American people now I
know this is slow I know this is
frustrating but we are now finally
making serious progress and according to
the DOJ inspector general's statement it
says in part quote as part of this
examination the OIG also will review
information that was known to the DOJ
and the FBI at the time the applications
were filed from or about an alleged FBI
confidential source this is interesting
additionally the OIG will review the DOJ
and FBI's relationship and
communications with the alleged source
as they relate to the FISA Court
applications in order for this
investigation now to be successful it
must answer the following questions and
these are only a few of many what did
the FBI really know about the Steele
dossier and when did they know it this
is critical
what was the FBI's relationship with a
foreign national by the name of
Christopher Steele who used Russian
sources was the FISA warrant against
Carter Paige politically motivated and
did political bias influence the FBI or
DOJ during the Russia investigation now
my message tonight to the FBI and DOJ is
turn over the 1.2 million documents that
Congress is now subpoenaed and it's time
to appoint the special counsel because
you cannot ever investigate yourself
when this brings us to our next breaking
story congressional investigators from
the freedom caucus the only guys doing
any work in Washington they have now
unearthed tonight even more text between
anti-trump lovers Peter struck and Lisa
Paige remember there are over fifty
thousand struck page text this is but a
small sampling of what they believe
could reveal damning new evidence that
the FBI the Obama White House and the
CIA and the deep State and the Intel
community we're all working together in
order to open up a politically motivated
Trump Russia collusion investigation now
let's explain why congressional
investigators you know think this is
important now according to one text
message from struck two lisa page august
2nd 2016 struck makes a reference to the
first interagency meeting discussing
coordination between the FBI and the DOJ
on the DNC hacking case this is what
struck rights quote
thanks so much for having the discipline
to wait another 24 hours to have the
first meeting about the case with the
DOJ now these congressional
investigators that we spoke to tonight
they believe this is evidence that the
FBI and DOJ met to discuss the Russia
election hacking investigation and then
get this August 25th 2016 this Harry
Reid he's briefed by then CIA director
you know the guy that voted for the
Communists in the 70s how did he ever
become the CIA director anyway with John
Brennan about Russia's attempts to
influence the election and then two days
after that meeting Harry Reid sends a
letter to then FBI director James Comey
urging him to open an investigation into
all Trump he wrote at the time the
evidence of a direct connection between
the Russian government on Donald Trump's
presidential campaign continues to mount
after the letter became public struck
then tex lisa page a link to a New York
Times article referencing the
letter-writing quote here we go oh maybe
that's sort of like their insurance
policy next the FBI ultimately use that
letter as legitimate cover for their
investigation into Russia collusion and
as a part of their FISA warrant
application against Carter page a trump
campaign associate that gets them all
the emails that gets them right into the
heart of the Trump campaign in other
words this was a coordinated effort to
spy on bring down and tarnish the Trump
campaign Sarah Carter in-house Intel
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez will be
here tonight and they will explain all
of this to you and while we continue to
bring you information on the deep state
forces that are working to take down the
president that worked to make sure that
President Trump never got elected well
the FBI is stonewalling the American
people and Congress when it comes to
these requests for documents related to
three important topics including the
department's investigation into
Clinton's email server information about
potential PI's abuses and the
justification behind why Andrew McCabe
was fired from the FBI
you know the release of documents has
been extraordinarily slow as a matter of
fact it almost sounds like obstruction
to me it's so slow that the House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Bob
Goodlatte
while he was now forced to issue a
subpoena in the Washington Examiner in
York is reporting the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions is absolutely livid and
apoplectic with the FBI director
Christopher ray and his slow compliance
with these important requests give us
these documents know in response as we
reported last night director ray is now
promised to double the amount of staff
working on releasing the documents and
he's going to double up their shifts but
is this too little too late should have
contempt a court order be issued if the
FBI does not comply with Goodlatte
subpoena
all right that's an important question
now we turn our attention to another top
story worth
following the media erupted into a
frenzy today absolutely goes nuts over a
story in The New York Times speculating
the quote Trump's lawyer raised the
prospect of pardons for general Flynn
and Paul Manafort one little itsy-bitsy
teeny-weeny little problem with the
story it's fake news and we know because
one of trumps lawyers Ty Cobb put out a
statement it reads I have only been
asked about pardons by the press and
have routinely responded on the record
no pardons are under discussion or under
consideration at the White House Oh fake
news Ty Cobb couldn't have been more
clear but that does not stop the corrupt
mainstream media from obsessing over the
story during today's White House
briefing we have the evidence take a
look
our pardons on the table for anyone
involved in the rush approach look I
would refer you back to the statement
from Ty Cobb and the report that you're
asking about and you say unequivocally
that no one here has discussed pardons
in this case I can say that Ty Cobb is
the person that would be most directly
involved in this I'm wondering if the
President believes he has the right to
use the power of his office the power to
pardon to protect them from what he
might see as unfair punishment down the
road does he believe he has that right
look I would refer you back to a tie
cobb statement as we considered easy
considering would he consider pardoning
Palmetto Ford Michael Flynn or rickets
as I said an on record statement from
the president's attorney here at the
White House on these matters has said
there's no discussion or consideration
of this did the president direct John
to talk to the attorneys of havana port
and michael Flynn about the potential
darkness I'm not aware of any
conversations of that nature at all so
while everyone in the press corps today
appeared to be on the same page over
this of course bogus New York Times fake
news story one of the fake news
reporters didn't quite get the memo and
of course he works for fake news CN n
Jim Acosta he was preoccupied still with
stormy stormy stormy stormy take a look
thanks so much guys have a great rest of
the way
now of course it's not surprising coming
from fake news CN n led by the very soon
to be scandal play king of porn Jeff
Zucker and by the way yeah we know and
today we also learned that creepy
Anderson Cooper you know the Jerry
Springer wannabe he's now going to be
hosting a town hall next month with Jim
Comey that's right Jim Comey's big
audition to become the next paid liberal
talking head at fake news or MSNBC
conspiracy theory news while he's
sitting down for a town-hall with CNN's
version of Springer hey James Comey I've
already told you you can divulge your
deepest darkest secrets to me I guess
creepy Anderson Cooper's your choice now
these are some of the questions by the
way Cooper's was was asking in other
words Jerry Springer jr. asking stormy
Daniels and Karen McDougal well check
out the creep factor so the sex was
consensual did he actually try to hand
you money did he bring up his wife would
he talk about his child his son were you
in love with him
did he ever compare you to any of his
kids did he ever use protection
you told Donald Trump to turn around and
take off his pants yes and did you yes
and you had sex with him yes
you were 27 he was 60 were you
physically attracted to him no not at
all no did you want to have sex with him
in an industry where condom use is an
issue did he use a condom no did you ask
him to now after you had sex what
happened physically you've seen him in
ways that other people haven't correct
and if need be I could describe that
his private parts and all you have to
say Jim Comey good luck and by the way
giving the upcoming investigation by the
DOJ is an inspector general that we
learned about today on potential Faiz
abuses you may Jim wanna rethink that
book in that book tour James Comey
remember in this country you do have the
right to remain silent now with that
said you're still welcome on this
program mr. Comey as I've said
repeatedly we'll give you the entire
hour this is the highest-rated hour in
cable news I'll also give you three
hours on my radio show on five hundred
and seventy plus stations all over
America it's time to give the American
people the answers they deserve why do
you continue to duck us I'm beginning to
take this personally